Hi.
In this problem, Romeo and
Juliet are back and they're
still looking to meet
up for a date.
Remember, the last time we met
up with them, it was back in
the beginning of the course and
they were trying to meet
up for a date but they weren't
always punctual.
So we modeled their delay as
uniformly distributed between
0 and 1 hour.
So now in this problem,
we're actually
going to look at variation.
And we're going to ask the
question, how do we actually
know that the distribution is
uniformly distributed between
0 and 1 hour?
Or it could also be the case
that it is uniformly
distributed between 0
and half an hour, or
zero and two hours.
How do we actually know what
this parameter of the uniform
distribution is?
OK, so let's put ourselves in
the shoes of Romeo who's tired
of being stood up by Juliet
on all these dates.
And fortunately, he's learned
some probability since the
beginning of course,
and so have we.
And in particular we've learned
Bayesian inference.
And so in this problem, we're
actually going to use
basically all the concepts and
tools of Bayesian inference
that we learned chapter
eight and apply them.
So it's a nice review problem,
and so let's get started.
The set of the problem is
similar to the first Romeo and
Juliet problem that
we dealt with.
They are meeting up for a date,
and they're not always
punctual and they
have a delay.
But instead of the delay being
uniformly distributed between
0 and 1 hour, now we have an
extra layer of uncertainty.
So if we know sum theta, then we
know that the delay, which
we'll call x is uniformly
distributed
between 0 and the theta.
So here's one possible
theta, theta 1.
But we don't actually know
what this theta is.
So in the original problem
we knew that theta
was exactly one hour.
But in this problem we don't
know what theta is.
So theta could also be like
this, some other theta 2.
And we don't know what
this theta is.
And we choose to model it as
being uniformly distributed
between 0 and 1.
So like I said, we have
two layers now.
We have uncertainty about theta,
which is the parameters
of the uniform distribution.
And then we have uncertainty
in regards to the
actual delay, x.
OK, so let's actually
write out what these
distributions are.
So theta, the unknown parameter,
we're told in the
problem that we're going to
assume that is uniformly
distributed between 0 and 1.
And so the PDF is just 1, when
theta is between 0 and 1, and
0 otherwise.
And we're told that, given what
theta is, given what this
parameter is, the delay is
uniformly distributed between
0 and this theta.
So what that means is that we
know this conditional PDF, the
conditional PDF of x given theta
is going to be 1 over
theta if x is between 0 and
theta, and 0 otherwise.
All right, because we know
that given a theta, x is
uniformly distributed
between 0 and theta.
So in order to make this uniform
distribution, it's the
normalization or the heights,
you can think of it, has to be
exactly 1 over theta.
So just imagine for a concrete
case, if theta were 1, 1 hour
in the original problem, then
this would just be a PDF of 1
or a standard uniform
distribution between 0 and 1.
OK, so now this is, we have the
necessary fundamentals for
this problem.
And what do we do
in inference?
Well the objective is
to try to infer
some unknown parameter.
And what we have is we have a
prior which is our initial
belief for what this
parameter might be.
And then we have some data.
So in this case, the data that
we collect is the actual
observed delayed
for Juliet, x.
And this model tells
us how this data
is essentially generated.
And now what we do is, we want
to use the data and our prior
belief, combined them somehow,
and use it to update our
belief into what we call
our posterior.
In order to do that, we use
Bayes' rule, which is why this
is called Bayesian inference.
So when we use Bayes' rule,
remember the Bayes' rule is
just, we want to now find the
posterior which is the
conditional PDF of theta, the
unknown parameter, given x.
So essentially just flip
this condition.
And remember Bayes' rule is
given as the following.
It's just the prior times this
conditional PDF of x given
theta divided by the PDF of x.
All right, and we know what
most of these things are.
The prior or just the
PDF of theta is 1.
The condition PDF of x given
theta is 1 over theta.
And then of course we
have this PDF of x.
But we always have to be careful
because these two
values are only valid for
certain ranges of theta and x.
So in order for this to be
valid we need theta to be
between 0 and 1 because
otherwise it would be 0.
So we need theta to be
between 0 and 1.
And we need x to be between
0 and theta.
And otherwise this would be 0.
So now we're almost done.
One last thing we need to do
is just calculate what this
denominator is, f x of x.
Well the denominator,
remember, is just a
normalization.
And it's actually relatively
less important because what
we'll find out is that this has
no dependence on theta.
It will only depend on x.
So the importance, the
dependence on theta, will be
captured just by
the numerator.
But for completeness let's
calculate out what this is.
So it's just a normalization.
So it's actually just the
integral of the numerator.
You can think of it as an
application of kind of total
probability.
So we have this that we
integrate over and what do we
integrate this over?
Well we know that we're
integrating over theta.
And we know that theta
has to be between x--
has to be greater than x and
it has to be less than 1.
So we integrate from theta
equals x to 1.
And this is just the integral
from x to 1 of
the numerator, right?
This is just 1 and this
is 1 over theta.
So it's the integral of 1 over
theta, d theta from x to 1.
Which when you do it out,
this is the integral,
this is log of theta.
So it's log of 1
minus log of x.
Log of 1 is 0.
X, remember x is between
0 and theta.
Theta is less than 1.
So x has to be between
0 and 1.
The log of something between
0 and 1 is negative.
So this is a negative number.
This is 0.
And then we have a
negative sign.
So really what we can write this
as is the absolute value
of log of x.
This is just so that it would
actually be negative log of x.
But because log of x is
negative we can just--
we know that this is actually
going to be a positive number.
So this is just to make it
look more intuitive.
OK so now to complete this we
can just plug that back in and
the final answer is--
this is going to be the absolute
value log of x or you
could also rewrite this as 1
over theta times absolute
value log of x.
And of course, remember that
the actual limits for where
this is valid are
very important.
OK, so what does this
actually mean?
Let's try to interpret
what this answer is.
So what we have is this is the
posterior distribution.
And now what have we done?
Well we started out with the
prior, which was that theta is
uniform between 0 and
between 0 and 1.
This is our prior belief.
Now we observed some data.
And this allows us to
update our belief.
And this is the update
that we get.
So let's just assume that we
observe that Juliet is late by
half an hour.
Well if she's late by half an
hour, what does that tell us
about what theta can be?
Well what we know from that at
least is that theta cannot be
anything less than half an hour
because if theta were
less than half an hour there's
no way that her delay--
remember her delay we know
has to be distributed
between 0 and theta.
There's no way that her delay
could be half an hour if theta
were less than half an hour.
So automatically we know that
now theta has to be somewhere
between x and one which is where
this limit comes in.
So we know that theta have to be
between x and 1 now instead
of just 0 and 1.
So by observing an x that cuts
down and eliminates part of
the range of theta, the range
that theta can take on.
Now what else do we know?
Well this, we can actually
plot this.
This is a function of theta.
The log x, we can just
think of it as some
sort of scaling factor.
So it's something like
1 over theta scaled.
And so that's going to look
something like this.
And so what we've done is we've
transformed the prior,
which looks like flat and
uniform into something that
looks like this,
the posterior.
So we've eliminated small values
of x because we know
that those can't be possible.
And now what's left is
everything between x and 1.
So now why is it also that
it becomes not uniform
between x and 1?
Well it's because, if you think
about it, when theta is
close to x, so say x
is half an hour.
If theta is half an hour, that
means that there's higher
probability that you will
actually observe something, a
delay of half an hour because
there's only a range between 0
and half an hour that
x can be drawn from.
Now if theta was actually 1 then
x could be drawn anywhere
from 0 to 1 which is
a wider range.
And so it's less likely that
you'll get a value of x equal
to half an hour.
And so because of that values
of theta closer
to x are more likely.
That's why you get this
decreasing function.
OK, so now let's continue and
now what we have is this is
the case for if you observe
one data point.
So you arrange a date with
Juliet, you observe how late
she is, and you get
one value of x.
And now suppose you want to get
collect more data so you
arrange say 10 dates
with Juliet.
And for each one you observe
how late she was.
So now we can collect multiple
samples, say
n samples of delays.
So x1 is her delay on
the first date.
Xn is her delay on
the nth date.
And x we can now just call a
variable that's a collection
of all of these.
And now the question is, how do
you incorporate in all this
information into updating
your belief about theta?
And it's actually pretty
analogous to
what we've done here.
The important assumption that
we make in this problem is
that conditional on theta, all
of these delays are in fact
conditionally independent.
And that's going to help
us solve this problem.
So the set up is essentially
the same.
What we still need is a--
we still need the prior.
And the prior hasn't changed.
The prior is still uniform
between 0 and 1.
The way the actual delays are
generated is we still assume
to be the same given conditional
on theta, each one
of these is conditionally
independent, and each one is
uniformly distributed
between 0 and theta.
And so what we get is that this
is going to be equal to--
you can also imagine this as
a big joint PDF, joint
conditional PDF of
all the x's.
And because we said that they
are conditionally independent
given theta, then we can
actually split this joint PDF
into the product of a lot of
individual conditional PDFs.
So this we can actually rewrite
as PDF of x1 given
theta times all the way through
the condition PDF of
xn given theta.
And because we assume that
each one of these is--
for each one of these it's
uniformly distributed between
0 and theta, they're
all the same.
So in fact what we get
is 1 over theta
for each one of these.
And there's n of them.
So it's 1 over theta to the n.
But what values of x
is this valid for?
What values of x and theta?
Well what we need is that for
each one of these, we need
that theta has to be at least
equal to whatever x you get.
Whatever x you observe, theta
has to at least that.
So we know that theta has to at
least equal to x1 and all
the way through xn.
And so theta has to be at least
greater than or equal to
all these x's and otherwise
this would be 0.
So let's define something
that's going to help us.
Let's define x bar to be
the maximum of all
the observed x's.
And so what we can do is rewrite
this condition as
theta has to be at least
equal to the
maximum, equal to x bar.
All right, and now we can
again apply Bayes' rule.
Bayes' rule will tell us
what this posterior
distribution is.
So again the numerator will
be the prior times this
conditional PDF over PDF of x.
OK, so the numerator again,
the prior is just one.
This distribution we calculated
over here.
It's 1 over theta to the n.
And then we have this
denominator.
And again, we need to be careful
to write down when
this is actually valid.
So it's actually valid when x
bar is greater than theta--
I'm sorry, x bar is less than
or equal to theta, and
otherwise it's zero.
So this is actually more
or less complete.
Again we need to calculate out
what exactly this denominator
is but just like before it's
actually just a scaling factor
which is independent
of what theta is.
So if we wanted to, we could
actually calculate this out.
It would be just like before.
It would be the integral of the
numerator, which is 1 over
theta to the n d theta.
And we integrate theta from
before, it was from x to 1.
But now we need to integrate
from x bar to 1.
And if we wanted to, we can
actually do others.
It's fairly simple calculus
to calculate what this
normalization factor would be.
But the main point is that the
shape of it will be dictated
by this 1 over theta
to the n term.
And so now we know that with n
pieces of data, it's actually
going to be 1--
the shape will be 1 over theta
to the n, where theta has to
be at least greater than
or equal to x bar.
Before it was actually just
1 over theta and has to be
between x and 1.
So you can kind of see how the
problem generalizes when you
collect more data.
So now imagine that
this is the new--
when you collect n pieces of
data, the maximum of all the
x's is here.
Well, it turns out that it's the
posterior now is going to
look something like this.
So it becomes steeper because
it's 1 over theta to the n as
opposed to 1 over theta.
And it's limited to be
between x bar and 1.
And so with more data you're
more sure of the range that
theta can take on because each
data points eliminates parts
of theta, the range of theta
that theta can't be.
And so you're left with
just x bar to 1.
And you're also more certain.
So you have this kind
of distribution.
OK, so this is kind of the
posterior distribution which
tells you the entire
distribution of what the
unknown parameter--
the entire distribution of the
unknown parameter given all
the data that you have
plus the prior
distribution that you have.
But if someone were to come to
ask you, your manager asks
you, well what is your best
guess of what theta is?
It's less informative or less
clear when you tell them,
here's the distribution.
Because you still have a big
range of what theta could be,
it could be anything between
x and 1 or x bar and 1.
So if you wanted to actually
come up with a point estimate
which is just one single value,
there's different ways
you can do it.
The first way that we'll talk
about is the map rule.
What the map rule does is
it takes the posterior
distribution and just finds
the value of the parameter
that gives the maximum posterior
distribution, the
maximum point in the posterior
distribution.
So if you look at this posture
distribution, the map will
just take the highest value.
And in this case, because the
posterior looks like this, the
highest value is in fact x.
And so theta hat map
is actually just x.
And if you think about it, this
kind of an optimistic
estimate because you always
assume that it's whatever, if
Juliet were 30 minutes late then
you assume that her delay
is uniformly distributed between
0 and 30 minutes.
Well in fact, even though she
arrived 30 minutes late, that
could have been because she's
actually distributed between 0
and 1 hour and you just happened
to get 30 minutes.
But what you do is you always
take kind of the optimistic,
and just give her the benefit of
the doubt, and say that was
actually kind of the worst
case scenario given her
distribution.
So another way to take this
entire posterior distribution
and come up with just a single
number, a point estimate, is
to take the conditional
expectation.
So you have an entire
distribution.
So there's two obvious ways of
getting a number out of this.
One is to take the maximum and
the other is to take the
expectation.
So take everything in the
distribution, combine it and
come up with a estimate.
So if you think about it, it
will probably be something
like here, would be the
conditional distribution.
So this is called the
LMS estimator.
And the way to calculate it is
just like we said, you take
the conditional expectation.
So how do we take the
conditional expectation?
Remember it is just the value
and you weight it by the
correct distribution, in this
case it's the conditional PDF
of theta given x which is the
posterior distribution.
And what do we integrate
theta from?
Well we integrate
it from x to 1.
Now if we plug this in, we
integrate from x to 1, theta
times the posterior.
The posterior we calculated
earlier, it was 1 over theta
times the absolute
value of log x.
So the thetas just cancel out,
and you just have 1 over
absolute value of log x.
Well that doesn't
depend on theta.
So what you get is just 1
minus x over absolute
value of log x.
All right, so we can actually
plot this, so we have two
estimates now.
One is that the estimate
is just theta--
the estimate is just x.
The other one is that it's
1 minus x over absolute
value of log x.
So we can plot this and
compare the two.
So here's x, and here is theta
hat, theta hat of x for the
two different estimates.
So here's you the estimate from
the map rule which is
whatever x is, we estimate
that theta is equal to x.
So it just looks like this.
Now if we plot this, turns
out that it looks
something like this.
And so whatever x is, this
will tell you what the
estimate, the LMS estimate
of theta would be.
And it turns out that
it's always higher
than the map estimate.
So it's less optimistic.
And it kind of factors in
the entire distribution.
So because there are several
parts to this problem, we're
going to take a pause for a
quick break and we'll come
back and finish the problem
in a little bit.